ORDER A WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT.
OF MADAM SECRETARY WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THURMAN HERE FLORA [inaudible]
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
JONES SAWYER.
KALRA [inaudible]
WE MUST [inaudible]
STEINORTH WARMEST.
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM AWAY ONE
BILL BEFORE US IT'S A. B. TWENTY
THIRTY TO THIRTY ONE SOME MEMBER
GRAY GIVEN THE HEAVY VOLUME OF
OUR LEGISLATURE AT THIS TIME I
APPRECIATE THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER IS WILLING TO
PRESENT THE BILL ON BEHALF OF
MISTER GRAY.
PLEASE RECEIPT WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU.
IF THERE WITNESSES PLEASE COME
FORWARD CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
SIMPLE BILL REQUIRES THE ANNUAL
REPORT FILED BY THAT VISION
APPROACH IT STANDARDS IN THE
CALIFORNIA APPRENTICESHIP
COUNCIL TO INCLUDE
APPRENTICESHIP STANDARDS THAT
WERE PROPOSED AND OR ADOPTED IN
THE PREVIOUS YEAR.
THE SENATE MEHMET'S PERMIT A
JAIL MC TO SEEK A COURT ORDER
COMPELLING EMPLOYER TO PROVIDE
PAYROLL RECORDS AS REQUIRED
UNDER PREVAILING WAGE
REQUIREMENTS IT'S GOOD BILL AND
EVERY.
SPECK COOLEY ASPIRIN AYE VOTE
BIG YOU FIRST WITNESS.
MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME'S MIKE WEST AND
I'M GONNA GO OFF SCRIPT FOR MY
PREVIOUS TESTIMONY OF ALREADY
HEARD THAT AS WELL TO GIVE YOU
AN EXAMPLE OF A PROJECT IN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALL SEN
DOWNTOWN SAN JOSE HEALTH CENTER.
CONTRACTOR OUT OF SACRAMENTO.
DID THAT JOB WAS AWARDED IT HAD
NO PLAN TO PAY ANY OF HIS
WORKERS.
DE I TRAVEL PAYING SO YOU KNOW
EXACTLY HOW LONG IT TAKES TO GET
FROM SACRAMENTO TO SAN JOSE.
OKAY -- AND
BASICALLY THAT JOB WAS PERFORMED
IN THE FIELD IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
TO THE FINAL DETERMINATION THAT
PAID BACK THOSE WORKERS TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN.
UNPAID TRAVEL PAID DIDN'T COME
DOWN UNTIL MARCH THIRD OF THIS
YEAR SO THIS BILL.
COMPELLING THE EXPEDITED
CERTIFIED PAYROLLS WOULD GET
THAT MONEY BACK INTO THEIR
POCKETS SOONER AND ALLEVIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR A BAD ACTOR TO
COERCE THEM INTO ACCEPTING A
SMALL BONUS OR REYES.
OR EVEN GIVEN THAT MONEY BACK
FOR THE PROMISE OF FUTURE
EMPLOYMENT AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOEPEL.
THANK YOU ITS WITNESS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
JEREMY SMITH YOUR BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT.
OF THE JAIL AND SEES WHAT THE
SAME THING THAT --
THE GOOD THE GOOD PEOPLE AT DIR
DLC ONE IS TO GET PEOPLE BACK
WAGES OF THE ROAD FOR WORK
THEY'VE ALREADY DONE.
LEADERSHIP AYE BUT ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
ADD ON IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST MY
CONSUMERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHING AT ON
IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SAME NONE --
WILL GO BACK TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR MOTION.
BILL'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE.
RESPECT THAT'S WHEN I ABOUT
THANK YOU THIS BILL IS ABOUT
BEFORE US OUT FOR CONCURRENCE
AND SENATE AMENDMENTS.
IT HAS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS RECOMMENDATION THAT
SENATE AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED
IN THURMAN.
AYE THURMOND AYE FLORA GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE JONES
SAWYER KALRA.
KALRA AYE REBUS REVERSE AYE
STEINORTH.
STEINORTH KNOW.
THAT BILL IS.
THAT BILL IS OUT CONGRATULATIONS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GREAT --
AND WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ANYONE IN THIS AT ALL AND WE
HAVE NO NEWS AT ALL.
WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
FIVE MINUTES FOR ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO ADD ON FOR NOW WE ARE
AT CHEN [inaudible]
WELL
.
JONES SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE
[inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
LARA I IT IS A JOURNEY